you ready me Beyonce and jay-z may be
the most powerful couple in music from
their first collaboration on Bonnie and
Clyde in 2002 girlfriend their secret
wedding in 2008 to the release of
Beyonce's self-titled album in December
they kept people guessing on their every
move including the state of their
marriage but gossip acai two combined 36
Grammys 20 solo albums 117 billboard top
100 songs and sold out global tours it's
no wonder they've become the king and
queen of hip-hop that success has
commanded high-priced endorsements
beyonce has inked deals with Pepsi
L'Oreal and American Express jay-z has
dialed in millions from Samsung and
struck deals with the Brooklyn Nets and
Barclays center not to mention starting
his own sports agency they also rules
social media having a combined 84
million Facebook fans over 16 million
Twitter followers and almost 15 million
following on Instagram
jay-z may have 99 problems but selling
tickets isn't one the couple's 19 shell
North American tour on the run has
grossed over 100 million dollars this
summer as Live Nation tells billboard
averaging roughly 5.3 million dollars a
night by some estimates on the run is
the second most successful tour of all
time after you tues 360 and just like
you to their appeal maybe forever yeah
you